now we start with some breaking uh news
about me
now this is really important
this was breaking news about me my
record is intact I have never ever ever
been to a White House correspondence
Gala ever did I say ever
and I'm very proud of that and uh by the
way I didn't go this Saturday so my
record remains intact thankfully all
right we begin tonight to a Fox News
Alert Up Up and Away here we go again as
another mysterious balloon just breached
U.S territory officials are now tracking
the UFO near Hawaii and while the Biden
Administration doesn't know what it is
or where it's from or who is flying this
thing they somehow know for certain
they're telling we the American people
that it poses absolutely no security
risk at all whatsoever
um why does that not pass the smell test
remember we still have no clue no idea
what the three objects were that Biden
and his administration shot out of the
sky with those four hundred thousand
dollar Sidewinder missiles so we're
going to keep you posted and uh if they
decide to shoot this balloon out of the
sky as well with another you know what
800 400 000 missile as per tradition
we'll let you know all right also
tonight Straight Ahead Vivek ramaswamy
will join us now yesterday he absolutely
schooled NBC's Chuck Todd on the
difference between a man and a woman
here's a preview
are you confident that you know that
gender uh is uh as binary as you're
describing it are you confident that it
isn't a spectrum I am do you know this
as a scientist
the best parts coming up we'll play the
full exchange straight ahead and by the
way terrible economic news has Biden's
banking crisis now rages on this is the
second largest bank collapse in American
history now remember in March he assured
every American that this was not a
banking issue and just like he said
inflation was transitory he gets
everything wrong so we'll get to that
tonight and coming up the sad tragedy
out of Texas where an illegal immigrant
who previously was deported not once not
twice not three not four times but five
separate times just brutally murdered
five innocent people including an
eight-year-old little boy now the great
one I talked to him before the show he
is really angry about all of this at
some point when do we call people out
that they have blood on their hands
we'll get to all of that and our wide
open Southern border but first tonight
we begin in Batesville Arkansas where
zero experience on her Biden appeared in
court today wearing a beautiful check it
out beautiful designer suit flanked by
some of the most expensive attorneys in
the world the president's adult son told
the judge that he was just too poor to
make child support payments
I'm not making it up
to the mother of his four-year-old
daughter now according to Hunter's
attorney the millions that he made from
Russia and China and Ukraine and all
these other countries uh apparently
they're claiming are long gone we'd like
to get an answer how much money did the
Biden family Syndicate make in China
Russia Ukraine Kazakhstan and all these
other places we know that some rich
donor friend of his bailed him out with
a 2.8 million dollar tax bill apparently
is one hundred thousand dollar Porsche
has been repossessed and it is unclear
if he's still paying rent on that twenty
thousand dollar a month Malibu mansion
now the celebrity lawyer from Hollywood
that paid off his tax bill also bought
him a new car it's great to have friends
in high places isn't it and apparently
Hunter is now so destitute that during
his recent trip to Ireland he had to
sleep on a cot and his in the
president's hotel room by the way I feel
sorry for Joe more than him because he
was unable to afford his own lodging
according to the them now does any of
you believe any of you believe this no
not his only income according to his
lawyers is from his work as an amateur
paint by numbers artist I call it Port
it's called portraits of a crack addict
but hunter is unable or unwilling to put
a value on the art even though his quote
masterpieces were reportedly selling for
anywhere between 75 grand and five
hundred thousand dollars a piece we
don't know who's buying them of course
his father the president is also ultra
wealthy despite working as a quote
public servant his entire life Joe Biden
has amassed millions and millions of
dollars and multiple mansions and yet
neither Joe nor Dr Jill guess that
they're not willing to lend a helping
hand for a four-year-old granddaughter
here's the saddest part they will not
even recognize their four-year-old
granddaughter no invites to the
granddaughter no recognition of the
granddaughter in the White House no
birthday cards no Christmas presents
nothing zip NADA he said last week that
he has six grandchildren will somebody
please tell the president that he
actually has seven grandchildren and
it's beyond time that Joe and Jill Biden
and invite this innocent four-year-old
little girl into their lives and
properly Embrace her with the love that
she deserves from her grandparents the
circumstances surrounding her birth are
irrelevant ignoring her is frankly
repulsive and now they're deadbeat son
is attempting to reduce or even
eliminate child support payments you
know the entire family should be ashamed
of themselves but the bidens have no
shame now just imagine for a second if
this was the Trump family and this was
Donald Trump not recognizing his own
granddaughter or not helping financially
his own granddaughter or grandson anyway
here's what Hunter had to say uh earlier
take a look
grandchild hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else